bonjour nidal reste merci de répondre à
nos questions en direct sur arte france
on vient de le voir avec le reportage de
passer mme siby les initiatives se
multiplient en tunisie avec notamment
une machine d'oxygénothérapie qui
utilise donc la technique de
l'impression 3d
en quoi ce défi technologique petit la
ralentir la pandémie bonjour donc nous
on a apporté une solution qui est en
route il a sion invasives pour les
patients les 15% des patients qui veut
soient atteints ou qui sont atteints
d'un kobe de 19 passes avant que ça
bascule en réanimation
parce que le coc vides y cause des
insuffisances respiratoires aiguës dans
5 % ils sont bien sûr au real il pas
sans rien et 15% peuvent reste soudé
problème de l'insuffisance respiratoire
sur lesquels on peut aider
le problème c'est maintenant au nez
comme comme tout au long de ces on est
en guerre contre cet ennemi invisible
donc du coup on nous on a essayé est en
pénurie de respiratoire qui existent
dans le monde plutôt vers l'afrique vers
la tunisie c'est de développer un
procédé simple disponible est facilement
réalisable dans une journée même une
demi journée on a réalisé la de
respirateurs à ventilation non invasive
donc à partir de là on apporte une
solution pas coûteuses comme adil m si
shell et le docteur qu avec qui on a
travaillé pour apporter une solution
rapide et apporter une au médecin un
respirateur qui peut aider pour les 15%
des cas quand vous dites pas
c'est quoi le prix est le prix ça
dépasse pas les 180 ou l'intelligence
artificielle et les robots qui viennent
donc on aide au secteur médical
qu'est ce que ça a traduit du système de
santé tunisien
des carences d'un point de vue
logistique et humain ou bien un avant
gardisme aux formes aussi un avant
gardisme c'est exactement c'est une aide
à l'infrastructure tunisienne en matière
de santé c'est bien que la tunisie puis
moi je suis content qu'il ya plusieurs
initiatives de développement à sousse à
tunis avait d'autres régions de tunisie
pour apporter une solution autour de la
robotique autour de l'intelligence à
fait artificielle pour combattre le
comité à 19 moi je suis vraiment flatté
de voir un peu comment ça se développe
comment les choses se mettent en route
en 2010 malgré le système qui qui peut
être saturé à tout moment c'est de santé
une nouvelle technologie donc du coup du
côté de la tunisie
et quid de des pays de l'union
européenne de la france notamment par
rapport à tout cela est ce que vous avez
été contacté
quelle façon on y travaille avec la
france avec d une entreprise française
tech 3 d en grand est où le grand est
rare en france il touché par l'épidémie
sur lesquels on développe ce genre de
procédé pour l'imprimer et en attaque on
travaille en étroite collaboration avec
eux pour la france et la tunisie et puis
pourra aussi verts voire vers l'afrique
pour si c'est possible de rendre le
dispositif disponible en open source
pour la rafle applications dans tous les
pays d'afrique il qui le souhaitent
l'utiliser
on l'a vu dans le sujet de basses mc
beal à la médecine tunisienne travaille
également sur un vaccin contre le corner
virus compétition ou coopération
mondiale à ce sujet ce que la lumière
peut venir de tunis je pense que
maintenant tout le monde se vérifie cela
et on en apprend tous les jours ce qui
se passe donc est le plus important
c'est que il faut qu'on travaille dans
les esprit collaboratif et non pas
compétitifs parce que l'humanité il faut
qu'elle se les fait se réunissent pour
combattre ce virus et toutes les
initiatives qui sont là ils sont les
bienvenus chacun porte sa petite pierre
pour avoir un virus après est-ce que le
virus est nécessaire est ce que le
vaccin est nécessaire ou non c'est une
autre question
mais tout le monde travaille ensemble je
pense est important de travailler tous
ensemble pour combattre ce le commis 19
on est favorite merci à nos règles
d'avoir répondu à nos questions je
rappelle que vous êtes directeur du
laboratoire de recherche
lg ipm